[Music]
hello and welcome i'm julie virgini and
this debate is on a matter of facts our
theme today's facts facts and reason
supposedly essential to make progress
and to make a better world at least
that's what we used to say now it seems
everybody has their own facts and world
leaders like trump and putin have their
own alternative ones but then they turn
around and claim that the so-called
facts of the liberal elite and the
mainstream media are equally dubious and
reason
facts hand-made and perhaps is derided
by many as a typically male bludgeoned
to deny alternative views so should we
welcome this challenge to facts and
reason as a progressive move undermining
the authority of traditional western
hierarchies founded on establishment
prejudice or is the undermining of facts
and reason singularly dangerous
threatening a belligerent world with no
shared framework and no communication
well i take it as a matter of fact that
we have an excellent panel to discuss
this grace chapel is professor of
philosophy at the open university in uk
and her areas of interest are
epistemology politics ethics and
feminism
professor of philosophy at stockholm
university anandi hatyanggadi's research
covers the philosophy of mind and
language epistemology and meta ethics
simon blackburn is a leading philosophy
professor and originator of the meta
ethical view of quasi-realism he says
he's not a proponent of popularizing
philosophy but he is certainly one of
our best communicators of it so welcome
to you all so we're going to just start
by giving you all three minutes to set
out your philosophical stall um i'm
going to start with just a very general
question
should we welcome
the challenge to facts and reason that
we're seeing and let's just take it from
the top um sophie grace trying to kick
us off
well should we welcome which challenge
to fact some reason there are a number
of challenges and some of them come from
various kinds of pragmatist philosophy
perhaps
and they're the more acceptable
challenges in my view and some of them
come simply from people who have a brute
lust for power and who want to get rid
of what is inconvenient to their
political agendas um so if people want
to have a
an
abstract discussion of what it means to
say that things are true or false
um then that's fine by me but when
people are bending um the notion of
truth to suit their own political
agendas when people are simply ignoring
facts
ignoring truths in order to
get their way in politics then i think
that's extremely dangerous i think
what's particularly dangerous in this
post-truth mood that we have
when for example michael gove says that
the uk public has had enough experts or
when president trump simply comes out
with utter nonsense about injecting
disinfectant i think that's profoundly
dangerous and profoundly retrogressive
actually it's not progressive in the
slightest it takes us backward not
forward and one of the biggest reasons
why well you can name a big reason from
the humanities if you like and a big
reason from the sciences the big reason
from the humanities is that i think um
it's crucial that in a democracy our
debate our discussion should be governed
by what i call conversational norms
which is the term i picked up from the
work of paul rice
in his wonderful paper logic and
conversation he talks about the norms of
conversation he talks about the norms of
communicating with each other and
griez says that norms are things like
willingness to listen to each other
making statements which include
everything that's relevant and true
and nothing that isn't
both relevant and true
one can i think get from grice's norms
which are meant just as logic and
logical and conversational norms one can
get actual ethical norms by thinking
about those a bit more and extending
them a bit more and the idea would be i
think that we're in a republican
conversation we have to respect each
other and even more than respecting each
other to echo aristotle we have to we
have to respect the truth that's a
crucial part i think of um humanistic
inquiry it's also a crucial part of
science for a very simple reason which
is that evolution filters out fact
recalcitrance over time if you don't
live in a way which respects the brute
facts and brute facts is perhaps the
right phrase here about how the world is
then you will die your species will die
out if you take disinfectant instead of
a vaccine for the virus you will die
it's as simple as that you'll get
selected out um it's not for nothing
that people talk of there being a darwin
award sometimes on the internet well the
darwin awards is an award for the it's
an award for getting yourself selected
out of the gene pool it's an award for
those who don't respect the facts
thanks very much and perfect timing
which is quite rare especially for a
philosopher i have to say so so good for
you um and andy what do you take of this
issue welcoming the challenge to facts
and reason and as sophie grace has
already pointed out
we have to say which challenges we we
welcome in which we don't it's not a
single question
yeah i think i agree i think there are
uh several different challenges uh to
facts and reason
um and i want to distinguish i want to
take a minute to distinguish two of them
that i think are particularly worth
mentioning one of them has been kind of
associated with left-wing progressives
typically in humanities departments and
it's a kind of relativist challenge the
other one is the thing that i think is
coming from the populists um and i'm
gonna say something about that uh next
so first the uh the challenge that comes
from the left from the progressives and
the academy is a kind of relativist
challenge that's grounded in
um the works of thomas kuhn for example
and the later wittgenstein
uh relativism about reason in this sense
is the idea that there are no standards
for reasoning that are really rational
that are really objectively the right
standards that you uh should adopt
across all contexts and all cultures uh
so there's no asymmetry uh really
between science and the norms of science
the norms that we adopt when we engage
in science as compared to astrology or
tea leaf reading
it's just that some norms are accepted
in some
cultures and some are different norms
are accepted in others
relativism about facts i think is this
kind of social constructivist idea that
facts are not chunks of reality that are
out there waiting to be discovered
rather the facts are something that we
project onto the world right um so
science again is not privileged as a
particularly effective way of coming to
know these independently existing facts
there's just different ways in which we
might construct them
so you might think that that kind of
challenge is to be welcomed right it was
you know when i was a grad student uh in
in the late 90s it was all the rage to
issue these kinds of challenges to fact
and reason and uh for many people this
came out of a kind of view that it was
aligned with progressive values in some
sense
so for example i think there were lots
of feminist critiques of science that
demonstrated the extent to which
sciences you know uh operates with
gender stereotypic uh biases
um and it seems like a natural extension
of this to say that it's not just the
you know the scientific research the
beliefs but the very logic and
scientific method are masculine
constructs
and this seems like some kind of radical
extension of the feminist project
second i think people thought that uh
relativism promotes tolerance in some
sense towards other ways of knowing
right because it allows us to validate
the belief systems of others we can say
for example that the azande belief in
witchcraft is you know true relative to
them and we can say that uh that you
know
believing on the basis of oracles is
rational relative to one set of
standards that seems to sort of be a way
of validating other ways of knowing
um but i don't think that this is really
i think this is super misleading so i
don't think that it is in fact
progressive um so on the one hand i
think um relativism just takes the sting
out of the feminist critiques of science
because if there is no really objective
rationality then we can't show that
science is biased against this objective
standard
um secondly i don't think that
relativism really is uh in itself uh
recommending that we should be tolerant
towards other views because it doesn't
really counsel anything of that kind at
all
okay i mean is the fact that you've had
significantly over three minutes so
perhaps we can uh save some of the more
thoughts for later particularly i'm sure
we'll come back to populism but thanks
for that
um simon um
what would you like to add to this store
this this set of stalls
it's sort of a market place of ideas
i've got very much to add i think both
speakers have uh set out things very
admirably um
i think that
um from the get-go in the 80s and 90s as
andy said
um when a certain kind of relativism or
anything goes sort of post-modernism
uh became all the rage in left-wing
circles
i always thought no there's something
wrong about this it's it's inflated for
example when people say that
everybody's got their own facts
that's an inflated way of saying that
sometimes people believe different
things we all know that
um you grow up knowing that
um and people do believe different
things
and if people say you know everybody's
got their own reasons
yes indeed some people will take
one thing as a reason for something and
other people don't
and so it's just something about which
people hold different beliefs or if you
prefer different attitudes
um
but of course it doesn't follow that no
one attitude is better
and often they are
our beliefs
uh form
in the wonderful words of frank ramsey
somebody
a cambridge figure not an oxford figure
like grice but never mind
um
he said that our system of belief is the
system with which we
confront the world with which we come to
the future
and in that system
there are certain fairly fixed points
that the earth is round that the sun is
about 92 million miles away that
some diseases are caused by bacteria and
others by viruses and so on there's an
endless number of things which you've
got to be dotty to challenge
and as sophie grace said if you do go
around challenging them
darwin will strike because
these are things which if you get wrong
you may die
because of you're getting that wrong
so i think there's no doubt that there's
a call that nearly everybody's sane is
going to share
they say president trump isn't going to
share it but
um then that just makes the point the
problem i think is not with people
having different beliefs
because we know how to argue about that
the problem i think is when people think
that somehow they've got a right to the
different beliefs
that it means that they don't have to
listen to other people
that you can retreat into a bubble or a
silo
and wrap yourself up and you don't have
to think anymore
and that's laziness it's also
inconsiderate and rude
and i think it's again ultimately
self-defeating
because if you don't test your beliefs
if you don't listen to other people's
arguments
then eventually you get fossilized you
become
stuck in some sort of rut
no guarantee at all that the rut is a
useful one no guarantee at all that it's
even one that's going to enable you to
survive and i think it's
inconsiderate
and consider i mean to take a very
simple example pertinent today i'll take
the anti-vaxx movement
now these are people who think that
there are reasons not usually stated
but doubting that the medical profession
knows what it's doing when it cancels
vaccinations
and who think that their own children
are sufficiently important
not to need
to assist others in becoming immune to
something like measles or whatever
and
i think they're inconsiderate
i think they're profoundly wrong in
their epistemology they're wrong in what
they believe about that vaccination and
about the medical profession
and i think they're very very dangerous
and worse than that i think they're very
very rude because by not listening to
other people
they're putting themselves on a pedestal
it's a sort of egoism
which um needs taking down a peg or two
i think
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you